welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for this
opportunity to engage in a discussion on
current challenges facing parents
using cannabis and pediatric conditions
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
jill swing
who will be available to answer your
questions following this discussion
for more information about our
participant please refer to the speaker
biography in the center of your screen
my name is dr kenton crowley and i will
be the moderator
for today's discussion this session
is interactive so please submit your
questions by clicking on
the ask a question box located in the
far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box
we will address your questions via email
following this discussion
jill swing is the president and founder
of south carolina's compassionate care
alliance she lives in charleston south
carolina
and has 12 year old twins
winfred and mary louise
mary louise has cerebral palsy
and a severe case of epilepsy
lack of positive results from
pharmaceutical drugs
lead jill in search of alternative
treatments
after learning about potential benefits
from cannabidiol or cbd for short
for seizures jill worked with state
legislatures to legalize access
to the cannabis derivative in 2014.
she has continued to support
legalization
of medical cannabis after discovering
that access to cbd
was limited and whole plant therapies
were often more effective she turned
a facebook group into a statewide
advocacy organization in 2017.
the mission of the scca
is to educate patients lawmakers
and communities on the benefits of
medical cannabis
so welcome jill thank you for having me
appreciate being here well that's great
in south carolina south carolina's is
one of 17 states that still did not have
comprehensive medi have a comprehensive
medical cannabis program
what are some of the challenges facing
parents
who are seeking cannabinoid therapy for
their children
with chronic medical conditions
well that is a very important question
and i
and i thank you for asking it um
it's also a very um
complex question because there are a lot
of challenges
obviously with our state not being one
of those
that has legal access to medical
cannabis
currently we are a cbd
hemp state so for patients who are
interested in cannabinoid treatment
that's really kind of where we draw the
line legally at this point
now the challenge just in cbd itself
is multi-tiered first of all
um we don't have physicians who are
educated
on cannabinoid therapies
and specifically cbd which is what we
have legal access to
so when we go to our physicians
and we want to have a conversation with
them about adding cbd
to our child's you know medicinal regime
you know they don't know whether it will
be beneficial they
don't know whether it will have
interference with
current pharmaceuticals so there's a
there's a knowledge
from the physician standpoint um so
that's
that is a starting point um
and some physicians have taken it upon
themselves i can't i shouldn't i
shouldn't
blanket safe doctors in south carolina
don't know anything about it there are
some doctors
who fortunately have taken the time to
educate themselves
and musc which is the medical university
of south carolina did
participate in the epidiolex clinical
trial
um so there are physicians who are at
least familiar with
the um the epidiolex but again that's
very very limited
like for my own daughter she doesn't
quali we tried to get her in the
clinical trial she didn't qualify
because she didn't have one of the two
um specific
conditions for which the epidialex
clinical trial
was um was being administered so um and
even
even today if we wanted to have access
to
the pharmaceutical epidialex cbd
we would be off label and so there's
questions as to whether
um insurance and medicaid would even
cover the expenses of of that medication
um so that's the first tier challenge
and so then going back to
you know staying within the idea of
source um
right now um cbd is
legal to be sold within the state of
south carolina
but again um it it's one of those things
that's just sort of
taken off and it's everywhere it's it's
in every
grocery store and every um gas station
i mean it's you know some retail stores
you can buy it online
and so then it becomes so the next
question is you know how do we get
a reliable source or how do we know that
that source is reliable
and as consumers
we're not yet sophisticated enough to
make that determination it's kind of
like when i
walk into the grocery store and the
the wine aisle i mean i i tend to go for
something with a pretty label and maybe
a price
point you know maybe not the cheapest
but certainly not the most expensive and
so
um cbd as you know as
a consumer i i kind of think that that's
where we are at this point it's like oh
well which one has the
the most appeal um because there's
little known about
what um the contents are in that bottle
um it's it's a self-regulated market and
some products are good
and reputable and um others
are um you know don't necessarily have
contain what they um what they say they
contain
as far as the label um so
that is definitely a challenge um and
then we've had
instances um i have been contacted
previously by parents
who actually um used
cbd for their children and
bss was called on them and i know of at
least one case
where a child was taken from from his
mother
um for using cbd oil he had chronic
migraine
um and the school noticed he was he
missed a lot of school i guess and the
school noticed that he was
he was doing better and he was attending
school and they asked if he was taking
in any new medication that was helping
he said yeah i'm taking cbd oil and i
guess
they had a concern called dss and dss
when they came
you know the parent cooperated she
didn't see anything wrong with it
he was thriving he was his health had
improved
um and like i said again it's legal here
um but was unfamiliar with what cbd was
do did a quick google search and found
out it was
it came from marijuana and her
understanding of what she read was that
this mom was giving her child
marijuana and they took the child into
dss
custody she did get her child back but
um this was a single mom with limited
resources
to actually have epilepsy herself and
that's why she had
cbd in her home in with
um you know didn't work a full-time job
because of her
medical condition um so it was it was a
challenge and it's scary when you think
okay this is a fully
product but there isn't this vast
knowledge of
um what is legal and what is not legal
and there are no protections under the
law
at this time um regarding things like
see you know like um dealing with dss
so that's just the cbd
portion now when you get into
whole plant that is not legal at all in
our state
and so right now our biggest challenge
is moving the legislature to
get to a point where they see and
understand the benefit
or the potential benefit of having a
safe and regulated market so that we do
have
access to products that are tested
and labeled and this interaction with
our physicians in consultation with our
physicians and monitoring by our
physicians
so that's the ultimate goal so i know
that was a lengthy question but there
was a lot
in there that i felt like was important
to share
because i think so many states have
legal access now that
um many of them may take it for granted
and
they kind of forget what it was like it
may not have been
been aware like prior to um having just
like
that provided protections for patients
so jill how did you get involved in your
advocacy efforts
um well when my daughter was
six years old she had she was really
struggling
with her seizures she's very high
frequency so 800 to 1 000 seizures a day
easily
and we had tried a multitude of
pharmaceutical drugs
combinations we did the ketogenic diet
we had seen specialists up and down the
east coast
and we just weren't getting any answers
and
our her neurologist actually reached a
point where he said you know i just i've
got nothing else for you i really have
nothing else
and we had seen the sanjay gupta weed
story
um where a little girl in colorado had
gotten access to cbd that's how i
learned about it and he said you know
it's worth looking into
and when we did what we found was that
we couldn't get it in south carolina
um and if we wanted to get it in
colorado
you couldn't just fly out there and get
it and bring it home
because you know even though now it's
being sold nationwide
um under hemp um as a hemp
product back then the the federal farm
bill
um legalizing the cultivation of hemp
had just been passed
and state legislature legislatures were
just starting to get caught up with that
so nobody was actually really growing it
um at that point so these were all cbd
products that were derived from
marijuana
and so this was very early on
and so you couldn't just go to colorado
and get it and bring it home because
that would be considered drug
trafficking
if you went there for treatment you
actually had to move there
um which means you you couldn't really
come back
and a lot of a lot of people in south
carolina made that choice because they
had children who were very very ill
and they were desperate and they
separated themselves from their families
and moved out there and that just wasn't
really a good option for me
so i was actually fortunate that my
mother-in-law lived down in beaufort and
had a mutual friend with the state
senator down there
and she had she was talking to this
friend about
her granddaughter my daughter and um
he said well you know i have a colleague
in my law practice who happens to be a
state state senator you know maybe
there's something he could do to help
out
so they met and then we met and
he did some research and found that
there was an old
law on the books regarding from 1980
regarding
legalizing marijuana for certain
conditions
to be administered through our dhak
which is the department of health and
environmental control
so he kind of took that at the bare
bones of that
and created um a cbd bill that basically
just legalized
cbd oil for patients with epilepsy
provided they had a doctor's certified
letter stating that they did have severe
epilepsy
and had failed multiple pharmaceuticals
and that they might benefit from the use
of cbd oil
so my mother-in-law and i spent a lot of
time
up in columbia where our state house is
located we met with lawmakers we wrote
letters
we testified we met the governor's
office
and at the time our lawmakers really
didn't know a whole lot about it but
they kind of just said well if it helps
sick children
how can we not support it right so the
bill got passed
rather quickly but the problem was once
it passed
and i got my daughter her certified
letter
um i was still empty-handed because
you know we didn't actually legalize
anything we just said something wasn't
illegal in certain circumstances yeah so
it didn't provide us
with access um and so
that was um an eye-opener for me
and also for a lot of people across the
state who
um i had in the meantime i had actually
started a facebook group which is the
name of my organization
south carolina compassionate care
alliance and
i started this facebook group because i
wanted to provide
other parents and other patients across
the state with information hey
this cbd bill passed but here's what it
is here's what it isn't
because people don't have a good general
understanding of how the legislative
process works
and they also didn't have a complete
understanding of what cbd was
they just thought it was marijuana and
so i would have patients who said i work
in the food and
beverage industry and if it's legal can
i just
get something from one of my co-workers
and give it to my child and i'm like no
um so that's really where the the
background um
started you know was with the cbd bill
and
um again i've just i found in my years
of doing this that
people don't know who their lawmakers
are
they don't know who to reach out to um
they're concerned that if they are using
something illegally now that if they
tell their lawmaker that that they're
going to get turned in
and that's really not the case i i found
that to be
quite the opposite that the lawmakers
are very understanding and they keep
those conversations confidential
and they are very compassionate people
and so
i feel like it's my job because i've
been doing this as long as i have to
continue to educate individuals
on on how to do that
wow what an amazing story
um well what can parents do now
to assure that they're getting safe
good quality products for their children
well um like i said obviously in the
beginning especially that was a real
challenge
and we were very desperate
um we had children who were suffering
and it's very difficult as a mom to
watch your child
suffer so we networked through
other parents and other parents in other
states and friends and friends of
friends
and got access to whatever we could get
our hands on
and this time at this time early on
these products were all black market so
um one thing i would urge
parents to use extreme caution
with the the sources that they're
utilizing
because we were sold products that we
didn't even know if they were fit for
human consumption let alone whether they
were going to benefit our children
and that was just just a risk that we
you know that we had to take um
because we were desperate and we wanted
to help our kids um
so you know one thing that i would
urge is to make sure you have a reliable
source
so how do you do that because cbd is
everywhere now
um like i said earlier it's on the
internet it's at the grocery store it's
at the gas station
um one thing you can do
is i would do i would do a pretty
thorough google search
on your manufacturer and find out a lot
of these companies are white labeling
and a lot of them all have the same
source with a different company name on
them
um so find out who you know who their
source is
make sure it's um you know it's
domestically
cultivated and also make sure that
there's a certificate of analysis
and if a company is not willing to put
that la that's and what that is is
actually it's a laboratory it's a
third-party laboratory test
um and so if companies aren't willing to
put their laboratory test um and it's
usually
by batch and the bottle will have a
label
with a barcode on it just like any you
know product you purchase
and that bar code will match that batch
will match
exactly with the the lab report for that
product
um so that is really you know that's the
best assurance and then like i said make
sure that the company
is reputable um ask around ask
other parents ask you know
what what other parents are using
because word of mouth is also
a great a great tool and a great
resource because
when we when we first started out we
were the very first cbd oil i gave my
daughter was called
sunflower power and all it said on it
was 20 to 1 cbd
well i didn't even that sounded good
somebody told me that's what you needed
for epilepsy was 20 to 1.
i don't know and but now i know 20 to 1
doesn't really mean anything because you
have to know what the one is
you know what the 20 is so
um you know it's just um you know it was
a learning curve and you know like i
said i mean even
you know we we had an occasion where we
were sold products that were labeled
um that had no we found out later
through
laboratory testing that they had no
traceable amounts of cbd in them
whatsoever
and those companies are out there um
they're out there to make a buck
and you know fortunately the fda has
cracked down
on some of those companies um that have
um
false labeling um but you know with so
many companies out there now
it's really difficult to um
to you know for the fda to keep up with
all of them and track them down if
they're
if they're bad players um but since this
is not regulated by the fda
this is a self-regulated market some
companies
have higher standards and are assured
making sure that the products they are
producing
are what they say they are that they are
safe that they do
utilize third-party laboratory testing
that you know there are no residual
solvents or molds or
microbes that could actually cause
damage to patients
um making sure that those are not
present or not present at levels where
they could potentially cause harm
so um being an educated consumer is
really
vital in this market that's
that's a tremendous
set of comments and guidelines that all
parents should follow it's critically
important
to know that the company that you're
using
is actually legitimate there's some
estimates
that there are over three thousand
companies
providing hemp based products in the
united states today
if you had a crystal ball what do you
foresee in the near future
regarding medical cannabis in south
carolina
and you know i was uh privileged to
attend the la
the last medical university at south
carolina's conference that
that you uh put on
um and got to meet and spend a little
bit of time
with one of your state senators tom
davis
um give us an idea of how you see
uh you know his uh efforts in
champion legalization and
and your experience in in this space
today
well um i i pretty much threw the
crystal ball out the window last week
when we all got put on shot
shut down because of the coronavirus
[Laughter]
um if you asked me that question a week
or two ago i might have had a a
more articulate answer but um
today i i i don't know that the crystal
ball
theory is going to be really helpful um
and i always do say
because i've done this as long as i have
that i just can't predict what's going
to happen at the state house
crazy things happen i mean one day we
thought our bill was going to be heard
and pass on the floor
and it happened to be clemson day and
um so the entire you know floor was
filled with orange and everyone was
you know celebrating clemson and um
so they basically ditched the calendar
for the day and then the bill didn't
pass till the next day but you know so
crazy things happen um a pandemic is not
something i could have possibly
predicted
so um i know that senator davis has
worked
very very hard this session
in first of all drafting a
really phenomenal phenomenal bill um
to on the get-go and you know after a
few few years of this and listening to
concerns
and listening to advocates and listening
to stakeholders
um and looking at what other states are
doing um he's he
he started out with a really terrific
bill but
then you know there's still the
naysayers there's still those who
you know want to proceed with even more
caution who want it narrower
and so he has sat down with so many
different groups with the south carolina
medical association and law enforcement
and victims advocates and religious
groups and i mean literally everyone who
has something to say
on this piece of legislation and he has
taken that into account
and he has you know and and and there
are complaints from
the advocates you know from the
grassroots folks saying this feels so
narrow it's not going to help anyone
but he knows what he needs to do to get
that bill
through the senate once the bill gets
through the senate
um we've got the support and the ability
to get it passed in the house it's just
going to have to be very very tightly
narrowed
in the senate and so i mean he
he knows he knows what he needs to do
and he's working that plan um
unfortunately
in fact we were supposed to have a
hearing on the bill today in the senate
and senate medical affairs committee
and of course um that got cancelled
uh we were all supposed to have a
hearing next week on the house version
of the bill
also canceled so it's a little hard now
to predict i'm hopeful
that they will come back into session
and
you know see the need to go ahead and
get this thing
moved because you know we are in a
health crisis
and um you know i
you know it's i have no idea whether you
know cannabinoid therapy would in any
way
help um with the coronavirus but
certainly with
people's health in general um you know
obviously we knew there are benefits
so it's very possible that they could
um do extend the session into the summer
and finish things up
or it may be a situation where we have
to start a new
um in january but you know that just
sort of remains to be seen at this point
well we do know that
is one of the important physiologic
systems that do protect us
against infection and so
just theoretically it would make sense
that
if our endocannabinoid system was in
good shape
we would be able to weather a viral
infection
much better than those that had an
endocannabinoid
deficiency syndrome
that makes sense well
how can parents patients and other
supporters get involved in your advocacy
efforts
to help bring safe access to cannabis
products for patients
like your daughter
that's another great question so like i
said we do have an organization sc
compassionate care alliance we are
a charitable organization um we're
registered with the secretary of state
and we're in the process of finally
finalizing our 501c3 paperwork for the
irs
so we um we do accept donations
and financial support goes a long way
for any non-profit as you can imagine
we're very small
but we do a tremendous amount of work
our involvement with the musc
annual medical cannabis update
conference where we bring in
speakers from all over the united states
now
that is a huge huge benefit
to the medical professionals within our
state as well as
as interested parties it's a cme cle
accredited
conference and so that's part of our
work that we've been doing
we also sent several senators from the
medical affairs committee to maryland so
they can see firsthand what
a very high tech
cannabis medical cannabis cultivation
and processing facility and dispensary
look like
because i feel like they still have so
many questions that were unanswered
and seeing it firsthand made a huge
difference so that's where a lot of our
funds have gone in the last years really
you know like i said that education
piece
but for individuals um i i
cannot stress enough the single most
important thing you do you can do
is contact your lawmaker and tell your
story
and tell them why it's important to you
that
they um that they support the
compassionate care act
um and there is a link on our website
which
is www.sdcompassion.com
where they can look up their lawmakers
or they can go to
www.scstatehouse.gov
and click on find your legislator and
then you put in your address and it goes
straight to who your lawmaker is
we also have a click to advocate button
on our website so you can
click that button and it sends a letter
directly to your lawmaker
but i still recommend following up with
an in-person meeting or a phone call
um just so they they can hear your hear
your voice
and understand your passion and your
need for medical cannabis
you don't have to be an expert you don't
have to be an expert on the bill you
don't have to be an expert on the
science
you know you you know your personal
story
and that's really what resonates with
lawmakers
so there are scientists that are
physicians there are researchers
that are also meeting with lawmakers so
let them do their job you do your job as
a patient and as a supporter of the bill
and and share your perspective because
that's really what
um what lawmakers are looking for from
their constituents
that's tremendous advice
that all of our viewers take that to
heart
the voice of voters really does make a
difference
and when it's personalized it even makes
more of an impact as as jill
and and i have experienced uh in in the
states that i
operate in yeah and i was actually going
to say
that that um that's important you know
that's every bit as important in a state
that has a legal
program now because of course there's
always there's always a need for
improvement
no state has a perfect program yet um so
be involved and and unfortunately as
as gross as it kind of seems be
politically involved
um you know we are south carolina is a
red state and i've personally gotten
very
involved in the local charleston county
republican party
and this is a topic that i bring up
quite often
at meetings we have had medical cannabis
panels at some of the republican party
meetings
and i spearheaded the adoption of a
resolution by the charleston county gop
in support of the medical cannabis bill
and none of that
would have happened if i hadn't been you
know really involved
in in pushing this issue um
in within my county um so you know
it it really does make a tremendous
impact if you can
if you can show up show up to these
meetings
talk about medical cannabis and um and
you know and tell your story
great guidance
well i'd like to thank jill for her
informative answers and thank you to our
wonderful audience today
for your thought-provoking questions you
may continue
submitting questions and our speakers
will follow up via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we'll see you next time
thank you